oui
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée à edouard durand et les depuis
janvier le coprésident de la commission
sur l'inceste et les violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants
il est également juge des enfants dont
j'aurai droit durant merci de m'accorder
cet entretien alors vous êtes également
connu pour votre lutte pour la
protection des femmes et des enfants
vous montrez de fortes qualités
d'empathie un véritable combat alors à
l'heure de la libération de la parole
sur le viol sur l'inceste est ce que
cette période est charnière pour votre
combat
oui je pense que l'on peut dire que
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison nous prenons conscience que la
maison doit être pour les humains le
lieu de la sécurité et de la protection
et nous assistons à un moment où les
victimes de violences sexuelles
les victimes de violences sexuelles dans
l'enfance et notamment d'inceste les
victimes de violences conjugales disent
les violences qu'elles ont subi leur
souffrance et un moment où la société se
sent responsable de la sécurité qu'elle
doit donner aux personnes dans la maison
et donc c'est très important
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler
des chiffres justement des violences
sexuelles commises sur les enfants oui
il nous savons que malheureusement les
données chiffrées dont nous disposons
nous permettent de voileux les violences
sexuelles c'est aux enfants sont un
phénomène d'une très grande ampleur
comme les violences sexuelles faites aux
adultes et plus spécifiquement aux
femmes même si des sommes aussi en sont
victimes et à partir des données dont
nous disposons des enquêtes de
victimation et du rapport entre les
déclarations
victimation en tant qu'adulte et les
proportions d'appels aux services d
coûte correspondant aux violences faites
aux enfants à la part dans l'enfance des
violences subies
nous pouvons penser que nous avons une
société où il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles c'est donc une proportion
extrêmement important bien sûr la
commission indépendante sur l'inceste et
les violences sexuelles faites aux
enfants devra procéder à des enquêtes
pour affiner ses données mais nous
savons que nous avons un combat très
volontariste a mené collectivement pour
renforcer l'intégrité et la liberté des
personnes non vous qui avez traité des
dossiers de centaines d'enfants en tant
que juge est ce que vous pouvez nous
parler de l'impact de ces violences sur
l'enfant sur leur vie nous savons que
les violences sexuelles les violences
faites aux enfants dans la maison
les violences répétées les violences
conjugales faites à la mère des enfants
sur les enfants un impact traumatique
gravissime que ces violences est tout
particulièrement l'inceste mais on peut
le dire aussi de du fait d'être témoins
de violences conjugales que toutes ces
violences nuisent considérablement au
bien-être de l'enfant à sa santé à sa
sécurité dans le temps présent de son
enfance mais qu'elles ont aussi un
impact très graves sur le développement
des enfants sur la possibilité de se
développer de façon normale adapté riche
pour développer leurs compétences leurs
capacités relationnelles et donc c'est
aussi la question de l'avenir
individuelle des personnes concernées
mais de la société dans son ensemble qui
est touchée cavité de ces violences vous
venez de publier un livre codirigé avec
la grande féministe ernestine ronai
violence sexuelle en finir avec
l'impunité
et aux éditions dunod c'est vrai que le
mot est fort mais les chiffres vous
donnent raison puisque les condamnations
pour viol par exemple reste minime alors
qu'est ce qui dysfonctionne dans nos
institutions pour qu'existe cette
impunité
oui ernestine ronai mois avant souhaité
que ce livre soit appelé en finir avec
l'impunité parce que l'exigence
collective que nous voyons se manifester
actuellement est de cet ordre
ce que le système judiciaire montrent
une grande sourd et vela sion des faits
de violences sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation parents montrent que nous
devons progresser beaucoup
bien sûr il faut dire et il faut
toujours commencer par dire que les
professionnels engagés sur le terrain
les policiers les gendarmes les avocats
les magistrats mais aussi les médecins
les assistantes sociales les éducateurs
déploient des trésors d'énergie pour
mieux prendre en compte la parole des
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
mais nous devons encore progresser et
nous devons progresser de deux manières
la première c'est par la loi pour que la
loi disent de manière très claire
l'interdît de la violence et ensuite
progresser parce que nous appelons des
pratiques professionnelles protectrice
ernestine ronai dit très justement nous
devons entrer dans une culture de la
protection
oui alors justement puisqu'on parle de
la justice
vous parliez des classements sans suite
des viols et a également énormément de
jeunes qui sont correctionnalisés donc
il ne passe pas devant la cour d'assises
alors si la justice a sa part dans cette
impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
alors il ya plusieurs manières bien sûr
la première manière
r ce que nous disons c'est qu'il faut
non seulement entendre la parole des
victimes mais la prendre sérieusement en
compte et la croire et ceci est très
important et c'est tout particulièrement
important lorsque nous parlons des
révélations de violences sexuelles par
des enfants en raison de la sous
réalisation massive de ces faits de
violence sexuelle en raison de l'état
des connaissances qui nous montre que
les fausses dénonciations sont
extrêmement résiduelles et en raison de
l'état des connaissances qui nous
montrent qu'un enfant qui révèle des
violences et qui perçoit qu'il n'ait pas
cru par la personne qu'ils l'écoutent
risque d'un effondrement psychique
il est possible de dire qu'il faut
croire l'enfant qui révèle des violences
c'est la première chose
et ceci passe aussi bien sûr par des
techniques d'enquêté notamment de
recueil de la parole des victimes et
dans le livre que vous avez bien voulu
citer nous avons des experts notamment
un psychologue attachée aux services de
la gendarmerie nationale et qui a des
développements extrêmement important sur
les techniques actuelles de recueil de
la parole des victimes pour arriver à
bien prendre en compte ce qu'elles
subissent et notamment intégré dans
l'interaction avec les victimes
l'impact du psycho trauma sur le récit
qui en est fait donc vous parler de
formation également peut-être
d'aménagement de lieux d'accueil d'un
dispositif de sensibilisation pour que
les victimes ait plus facilement
témoigné absolument vous avez raison
nous devons
renforcer notre capacité de donner
confiance aux personnes victimes de
violences et particulièrement de
violences sexuelles pour qu'elle puisse
de façon plus systématique pousser la
porte d'un commissariat d'une brigade de
gendarmerie d'un hôpital d'un tribunal
avec davantage de confiance des progrès
sont faits et nous devons nous inspirer
des pratiques professionnelles
protectrice les diffuser sur l'ensemble
du territoire pour améliorer notre
capacité de lutter contre les violences
il ya également d'autres pistes comme
cette proposition de rendre les viols
sur mineure imprescriptible ou encore de
condamner plus sévèrement les agresseurs
puisque très souvent la sortie du
verdict mais il ya assez peu d'années de
prison pour des violences parfois
extrêmes alors que peut-on penser de
cela et écoutez je pense à ce que dit un
pédopsychiatre spécialistes de la
clinique des enfants violents d'ailleurs
qui est le docteur maurice berger et qui
dit ceci valeur de l'acte valeur de la
sanction c'est très important
lorsqu'une juridiction prononce une
peine bien sûr elle prend en compte
plusieurs paramètres
mais il y à un paramètre qui est très
important qui est le dommage gravissime
causés à la personne qui a subi ces
violences et qui est attaqué dans sa
dignité dans son intégrité dans sa
liberté ce qui est en question c'est le
modèle de société que nous voulons
construire
d'ailleurs vous parlez souvent de
l'agresseur qui n'a finalement pas de
circonstances atténuantes parce que on
peut aussi voir la victime comme pseudo
consentante malheureusement c'est un
discours qu'on entend souvent et vous
vous êtes assez catégorique sur
l'emprise de l'agresseur ce que vous
venez de dire est très juste je vous en
remercie il y à quelque chose qui est
très important c'est que la violence
c'est toujours un choix
toujours un choix de passer à l'acte
contre quelqu'un il est toujours
possible de faire le choix d'un autre
comportement et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs nous ne parlons pas de
consentement ou non consentement mais de
stratégie de l'agresseur parce que à la
lumière de ce que le collectif féministe
contre le viol
pour les violences sexuelles ou ce que
ernestine ronai pour les violences
conjugales sont parvenus à
conceptualiser nous pouvons voir que en
dépit de la singularité de chaque
situation de chaque scène de violence
il y a toujours des invariants qu'on
peut appeler la stratégie de l'agresseur
ils recherchent sa proie
il isole il crée un climat de peur et de
terreur il passe à l'acte ils inversent
la culpabilité
il assure son impunité c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle une juridiction
pénale peut condamner un agresseur c'est
parce que c'est un choix de la personne
qui passe à l'acte par la violence et
qui avait d'autres moyens d'agir que la
violence on peut toujours se contenir
vous connaissez la phrase de camus un
homme ça s'empêche est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler de vos priorités dans
cette commission dans laquelle vous
travaillez à temps complet actuellement
j'imagine donc la formation fait rêver
la justice est ce que vous avez d'autres
choses prévues sur un calendrier par
exemple oui vous vous souvenez que le 23
janvier dernier lorsque le président de
la république nous a désignés
nathalie mathieu et moi même pour co
présider cette commission
il a très clairement dit à l'adresse des
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles dans l'enfance et notamment
d'inceste vous n'êtes plus seuls
on vous croit et le premier objectif que
la commission doit
peindre c'est d'organiser le recueil de
la parole des victimes cette commission
est l'une des réponses politiques aux
mouvements de libération de la parole
c'est à dire organiser ce recueil
témoigné une considération collective à
l'égard de cette parole proposer un
accompagnement social ou des soins aux
personnes en détresse ou en souffrance
et à partir de cette parole faire des
préconisations de politiques publiques
parce que nathalie mathieu et moi sommes
convaincus que si des personnes adultes
vont éprouver le besoin de dire les
violences sexuelles qu'elles ont subies
dans leur enfance et peut-être surtout
pour que la société protège mieux les
enfants aujourd'hui et demain
le deuxième objectif est d'augmenter nos
connaissances parce que quand nous
parlons de violence dans la maison de
violence de l'intimé de violences
sexuelles
nos représentations personnelles et
collectives sont toujours convoqué et
pour arriver à mettre à distance nos
représentations il faut injecter des
connaissances c'est à dire produire du
savoir procéder à des recherches des
recherches épidémiologiques pour arriver
à mieux définir le phénomène pour
ajuster les réponses
ensuite il y a bien sûr s'agissant de
politiques publiques un objectif
d'évaluation des politiques mises en
oeuvre par les institutions l'état les
collectivités territoriales
décentralisées les services associatif
habilité les différents services
professionnels qui interviennent dans le
champ de la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et de la protection des
enfants à partir de cela nous
parviendrons à faire des
expérimentations de bonnes pratiques
professionnelles en nous appuyant sur
les bonnes pratiques qui sont déjà mises
en oeuvre pour proposer ce que nous
appelons une culture de la protection
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection de soi
pas un mot mais une réalité merci
d'ordures on se retrouve après une
courte pause
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
édouard durant coprésident de la
commission sur l'inceste et les
violences faites aux enfants alors
edouard durant les députés ont voté le
15 mars pour fixer à 15 ans l'âge en
dessous duquel un enfant est considéré
non consentants dans une relation
sexuelle avec un adulte 18 ans en cas
d'inceste que vous inspire ce vote
ce vote m'inspire beaucoup de respect
cette loi est une très grande avancée
dans la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles contre l'impunité des
violences sexuelles et pour la
protection des enfants
nous l'attendions depuis longtemps et
notamment au sein du haut conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et des hommes
dont la commission violence est
coprésidé par ernestine ronai et moi
nous nous avions depuis 2016 recommandé
que soit inscrit dans la loi un seuil
d'âge en deçà duquel la contrainte de
l'adulte sur l'enfant serait présumé et
c'est ce que traduit la loi aujourd'hui
c'est très important parce que des
plusieurs affaires judiciaires avait
heurté l'opinion publique sur ce point
justement ce qu'il faut parvenir à voir
c'est la symétrie entre l'adulte et
l'enfant
ce qu'il faut parvenir à voir c'est que
l'acte sexuel ne pourrait pas avoir lieu
sans la contrainte exercée par l'adulte
sur l'enfant ce qu'il faut arriver à
voir enfin c'est que le passage à l'acte
sexuel de l'adulte est toujours une
perversion du besoin affectif de
l'enfant
ceci est très important et la loi devait
le traduire nettement donc il était
utile que ce seuil soit fixé à 15 ans et
c'est un progrès très importants
j'attire votre attention
sur ce point que la loi les faits pour
toutes les violences sexuelles avec ce
seuil à 15 ans et que dans le cas
particulier de l'inceste qui est un
crime absolument spécifiques
la loi est fixé ce seuil d'âge à 18 ans
alors justement vous dit que vous
l'attendiez de longue date et en 2018 la
proposition de loi très attendu pour
fixer l'âge du consentement avait été
retirée de peur que le conseil
constitutionnel juge qu'elle soit
contraire à la constitution alors que
s'est il passé est-ce que tout à coup le
conseil constitue aussi constitue
sionnel pardon a changé d'avis aurait
changé d'avis vous posez une question
très importante madame parce que il est
essentiel que les progrès réalisés par
la loi soient des avancées durable et
donc qu'elle puisse franchir le cap de
la constitutionnalité il était donc
essentiel qui est un examen attentif de
la loi au regard des principes
fondamentaux de nature constitutionnelle
qui avait été rappelé par le conseil
d'état dans son avis d'avril 2018
plusieurs principes que je ne vais pas
rappeler ici mais on peut les citer pour
mémoire le principe de la présomption
d'innocence le principe d'égalité devant
la loi pénale
le principe de légalité des délits et
des peines il fallait donc construire à
la lumière de l'avis du conseil d'état
d'avril 2010 8,1 textes ou des textes
qui soit conforme à ses principes qui
avait été rappelé et nous pouvons dire
nous espérons mais c'est ce qui a été
construit que le texte de la loi tel
qu'il a été voté la semaine dernière
pourra franchir ce cap de la
constitutionnalité pour que le pas
franchi ne soit pas suivie d'un recul
alors vous parlez de l'opinion la
pression publique tout alla et pour 2018
des affaires avait joué des affaires de
viols de mineurs
de 11 ans et cette fois ci je pense que
la sphère de julie qui se dit violée par
des pompiers a fortement contribué à
pousser cette loi comment analysez-vous
le rôle des citoyens dans l'avancée des
lois c'est un rôle qui est très
important bien sûr vous avez ce que
disait boutros boutros ghali ancien
secrétaire général de l'organisation des
nations unies le droit n'est jamais
innocent des sociétés qui le font naître
s'agissant de la lutte contre l'impunité
des violences sexuelles des violences
sexuelles contre les enfants
des violents conjugaux les mouvements
associatifs d'abord et la société dans
son ensemble
éclairez alerté instruite par une
succession de témoignages de victimes
depuis eva thomas dayer et tous les
grands livres qui ont nourri notre
pensée depuis plusieurs années vanessa
spring aura camille kouchner récemment
et bien la société porte en elle une
exigence de protection des victimes
spécialement de protection des enfants
et de lutte contre l'impunité des
agresseurs pourquoi parce que cette
parole des victimes qui créé une chaîne
de solidarité entre les victimes s'est
connecté à une conscience collective
nous nous sentons collectivement
responsables que de la protection que
nous devons et que nous devons tout
particulièrement à nos enfants
c'est donc un mouvement très important
et la loi devait le prendre en compte à
la lumière que des experts des experts
eux le juriste notamment au regard de
nos principes constitutionnels parce que
nous vivons dans un état de droit et
nous devons respecter les grands
principes qui nous font tenir ensemble
dans un état de droit mais comme je le
dis souvent nos principes n'ont jamais
été conçus pour faire écran entre le
réel et la justice il faut donc parvenir
à les mettre en oeuvre d'une manière
qu'ils soient protectrice de l'intégrité
de la liberté des personnes et donc de
la lutte contre l'impunité des
agresseurs votre cheval de bataille à
douar durance et qu'on protège mieux les
femmes des violences conjugales car
selon vos propres termes protéger la mer
c'est protéger l'enfant pouvez vous
développer
en effet madame vous avez raison c'est
très important
nous prenons conscience depuis quelques
années que les violences conjugales sont
un problème d'une très grande ampleur et
qu'elles ont un impact très graves sur
les saoudiens sont des victimes sur
leurs enfants et sur la société dans son
ensemble
rappelons d'ailleurs que les violents
conjugaux par leur impunité génère un
coût social annuel de 3,5 milliards
d'euros
il faut donc arriver à mieux lutter
contre les violences conjugales
l'un des problèmes est notamment que
nous avons tendance à séparer ce qui
relèverait d'un côté de la sphère de la
conjugalité et d'un autre côté ce qui
relèverait de la sphère de la
parentalité et parfois on dit notamment
un mari violent peut être un bon père il
n'en est rien au contraire car un mari
violent
un beau père violent créé sur l'enfant
un impact traumatique extrêmement graves
de l'ordre de l'exposition à une scène
de guerre ou de terrorisme donc qu'ils
portent atteinte de façon très grave au
bien-être et au développement des
enfants
il faut donc arriver à ne jamais
dissocier ce qui se passe dans la sphère
de la conjugalité et ce qui se passe
dans la sphère de la parentalité
car si on ne traite pas de façon adaptée
la sphère de la parentalité
alors le violent conjugale continuera à
exercer des violences et l'emprise sur
la mer et sur les enfants m'aiment
après la séparation du couple notamment
par l'exercice de l'autorité parentale
et par des droits de visite et
d'hébergement où il continuera à exercer
des violences sur la mer et sur les
enfants il faut donc que la loi et que
la société soit davantage dans une
culture de la protection là aussi
comprenez moi bien je ne dis pas tous
les hommes je ne dis pas tous les pères
jeudi ceux qui font le choix d'exercer
des violences contre leurs femmes contre
leurs enfants et que eux qui font que la
maison devient le lieu du danger alors
que pour les humains
la maison doit être le lieu de la
sécurité un père doit inspirer la
protection et la sécurité par la peur on
va aborder un autre problème environ 180
mille mineurs et des jeunes majeurs sont
accueillis à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
et récemment de très nombreuses enquêtes
des livres des témoignages évoquent des
abus des maltraitances au sein des
foyers au sein des familles d'accueil
est ce que vous partagez ce constat est
que faudrait-il faire tout système et
tout système de protection doit toujours
[Musique]
progresser et progresser avec la
capacité d'analyser ses propres
dysfonctionnements
il serait faux de dire que les enfants
confiés à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
parce qu'ils sont en danger dans leur
maison familiale ne sont pas protégés
par le dispositif de protection de
l'enfance cela dit il serait faux aussi
de dire qu'il n'y a pas ici ou là des
dysfonctionnements mais je peut engager
mes dix sept années de pratique des
fonctions de juge des enfants pour vous
dire que la très grande majorité des
assistantes sociales des éducateurs des
puits et les pulls trice des
psychologues
des familles d'accueil sont des
personnes compétentes et très engagée
pour la protection des enfants
mais vous avez raison il faut toujours
rester vigilant pour regarder comment
sont organisés les établissements
d'accueil où les familles d'accueil pour
observer le bien-être et le
développement des enfants et être
davantage en capacité de repérer si
l'enfant est heureux ou malheureux et
voire le cas échéant s'ils subi des
maltraitances des négligences ou
peut-être même des violences et de
manière générale quel que soit le lieu
où l'enfant si chez lui ou dans une
institution pour lutter contre les
violences et contre les violences faites
aux enfants
il faut être dans une pratique du
repérage systématique
posez la question aux enfants est ce que
quelqu'un a déjà fait du mal as tu déjà
subi des violences c'est une question
que je pose c'est d'ailleurs une
question que je pose aussi aux enfants
délinquants dont nous savons que une
très grande majorité sont des enfants
qui ont déjà subi des violences
je ne le dis pas pour excuser leur
passage à l'acte mais pour arriver à
traiter le traumatisme pour que l'enfant
puisse reprendre son développement et ne
pas passer à l'acte lui même
on le voit vous êtes un magistrat très
engagé dans la protection des femmes et
des enfants d'où vous vient cette
vocation
c'est une excellente question je dirais
que dans les premières années de mes
fonctions de juge des enfants
j'ai pris conscience de la gravité et de
l'ampleur des violences conjugales que
je me suis rendu compte que les
violences conjugales venait mettre en
question notre pensée collective de ce
que c'est qu'être un homme de ce que
c'est
être une femme de ce que c'est qu'être
un enfant et de ce que c'est que vivre
en famille et que nous devions
collectivement nous engager pour que la
maison soit le lieu de la sécurité et
c'est par la conscience de la gravité
des violences conjugales que j'ai
revisité ma fonction de juge des enfants
et la façon dont je devais l'exercer
vous savez un jour on a interrogé
emmanuel levinas en lui demandant
comment se mettront à penser s par les
livres est ce par l'expérience et
lévinas a répondu c'est par l'expérience
notamment une scène de violence et je
crois qu'il est possible de dire que
parvenir à voir la violence transforme
le rapport au monde
vous connaissez cette phrase de peggy
que je place pour ma part au sommet de
mon panthéon littéraire ce qui est le
plus difficile c'est de voir ce que l'on
voit or la violence ça fait peur
il faut donc que nous nous donnions les
moyens de voir la violence pour lutter
contre l'impunité des agresseurs ce sera
les derniers mots de cette émission
merci edouard durant douze avoir parlé
de la protection des femmes des enfants
je rappelle que vous êtes coprésident de
la commission sur l'inceste et les
violences faites aux enfants
vous avez également côte diriger le
livre violence sexuelle en finir avec
l'impunité aux éditions dunod avec
ernestine ronai vous pourrez revoir
cette émission reflets sur rt france
point tv à bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]